>>> YOU MAY RECA BACK
JANUARY 2011, GABBY GIFFORDS WAS
SHOT IN THE HEAD BY A GROUP OF
MEN WHILE MEETING TH A GROUP
OF CONSTITUENTS OUTSIDE ARIZONA.
SIX PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN THAT
SHOOTING, 13 OTHERS INJURED,
INCLUDING CONGRESSWOMAN
GIFFORDS.
THERE'S A NEW CNN FILM CALLED
"GABBY GIFFORDS WON'T BACK
DOWN."
IT'S IN THEATERS NOW.
IT PROVIDES A LOOK AT HER
INSPIRING FIGHT TO END GUN
VIOLENCE IN AMERICA.
HERE'S A PREVIEW.
>> THE SAME GIFT OF CONNECTION
AND THE SAME INDHAMENABLE SPIRIT
I SAW IN HER WHEN SHE WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO CONGRESS, THAT
DOESN'T GO AWAY.
GABBY EMBODIES THIS SENSE OF THE
HUMAN SPIRIT BEING AUTOMOBILE TO
OVERCOME JUST ABOUT ANYTHING.
>> I COULDN'T WALK.
I COULDN'T TALK.
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO ♪
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY DEAR GABBY ♪
>> NOW I'M GIVING SPEECHES
AGAIN.
♪♪
>> I'M STUDYING FOR BY BAH
MITZVAH.
♪♪
>> AND I'M RIDING MY BIKE MORE,
25 MILES IN TUCSON.
>> JOINING US NOW IS FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN GABBY GIFFORDS,
THE FOUNDER OF THE ANTIGUN
VIOLENCE ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
WHY DID YOU WANT TO UNDERTAKE
THIS?
>> I LOVE THE FILM "RBG."
DIRECTORS -- DO A WONDERFUL JOB
OF CELEBRATING WOMEN'S LIVES.
>> THAT'S FOR SURE.
AND WHY DID YOU TWO -- YOU DID
THIS DOCUMENTARY, "RBG," WHICH
EVERYBODY KNOWS ABOUT.
WHY "GABBY GIFFORDS," AND WHY
NOW?
>> WHAT A REMARKABLE COMEBACK
STORY, AN AMAZING LOVE STORY.
AND GABBY HERSELF, HERE IS A
PERSON WHO HAS FOUGHT BACK FROM,
YOU KNOW, THE MOST UNTHINKABLE
DISASTER, PERSONAL DISASTER, AND
NOW IS FIGHTING FOR SAFETY FOR
ALL OF US.
SHE -- WE JUST COULDN'T RESIST.
>> AND JULIE, I MEAN, AS A
PRODUCER, THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY
DIFFICULTIES.
GABBY HAS APHASIA, WHICH LIMITS
ABILITY TO SPEAK AT TIMES.
YOU INCORPORATED THAT IN THE
FILM, AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT'S SO POWERFUL IN
THIS FILM IS YOU REALLY SEE THIS
INCREDIBLE STORY THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT WAS
DEFINITELY A QUESTION THAT WE
HAD GOING INTO THIS PROJECT.
LIKE, WE WANTED GABBY'S VOICE TO
BE VERY MUCH THE CENTRAL VOICE
OF THIS DOCUMENTARY, AND IT IS.
AND OUR QUESTION WAS, LIKE, HOW
ARE WE GOING TO MAKE A FILM
CENTERED ON SOMEONE FOR WHOM
LANGUAGE IS SUCH AN ONGOING
STRUGGLE AND CHALLENGE?
AND WHAT WE LEARNED SPENDING
TIME WITH GABBY IS THAT IT'S
ACTUALLY SO FASCINATING TO SEE
WHAT SHE GOES THROUGH EVERY DAY.
SO, WE KIND OF MADE THAT PART OF
THE PROCESS OF OUR FILM.
>> YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
SEEN SO MANY HORRIFIC SHOOTINGS
THIS YEAR.
UVALDE, HIGHLAND PARK, THE LIST
IS LONG.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN LEGISLATION
THAT HAS BEEN BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION FINALLY THAT'S BEEN
PASSED.
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC RIGHT NOW
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR MORE
CHANGE?
>> I'M OPTIMISTIC.
IT WILL BE A LONG, HARD HAUL,
BUT I'M OPTIMISTIC.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS
READING UP ABOUT APHASIA IS
THAT -- AND YOU SEE THIS IN THE
DOCUMENTARY -- IS SINGING IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU DO AT TIMES
AND THAT -- I GUESS IT'S A
DIFFERENT PART OF THE BRAIN.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT WE LEARNED
IN THE COURSE OF MAKING THIS
FILM.
IT'S PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY.
GABBY WAS SHOT IN THE LANGUAGE
CENTER, WHICH IS WHY SHE HAS
DIFFICULTY, WHY SHE HAS APHASIA.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THAT MUSIC IS
LOCATED NOT JUST HERE IN THE
LANGUAGE CENTER, BUT ALL OVER
THE BRAIN.
SO, THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS IN
WHICH THE SPEECH PATHOLOGISTS
TRY TO ACCESS WORDS AND
LANGUAGE, THROUGH MUSIC.
AND GABBY'S A VERY MUSICAL
PERSON.
SHE LOVES TO SING.
SHE LOVED TO SING AS A KID.
SHE WAS IN MUSICALS.
AND YOU CAN SEE IN THIS
EXTRAORDINARY FOOTAGE THAT HER
HUSBAND, SENATOR MARK KELLY,
TOOK OF GABBY'S RECOVERY.
YOU SEE THE ROLE OF MUSIC AND
HOW THE THERAPIST USED IT TO
HELP GABBY REGAIN SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE.
>> HERE SHE IS IN THE EARLY DAYS
OF REHAB JUST LEARNING A FEW
WORDS AND YOU SEE HER BELTING
OUT --
♪ GIRLS JUST WANNA HAVE FUN ♪
♪ GIRLS, THEY WANNA HAVE FUN ♪
♪ GIRLS ♪♪
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD IT IN A
WHILE.
>> WE SAY IT'S A FEMINIST LOVE
STORY BECAUSE HE BECAME, FOR
QUITE A WHILE, THE CARETAKER,
THE SOMEBODY WHO WAS REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT GABBY WAS GOING
TO BE ON THE ROAD TO RECOVERY.
HE BELIEVED THAT SHE COULD DO
IT, AND HE REALLY HELPED HER DO
IT.
AND THEN WE SEE THE TABLES TURN,
WHERE MARK KELLY, THEN AN
ASTRONAUT AND THEN HE RETIRED
FROM AN ASTRONAUT, WENT INTO
POLITICS.
AND GABBY HAS REALLY HELPED HIM
IN HIS CAREER, AS HE BECAME A
U.S. SENATOR.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
TAKE AWAY FROM THE DOCUMENTARY,
FROM THE FILM?
>> FOR ME, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO MOVE AHEAD, TO NOT LOOK BACK.
I HOPE OTHERS ARE INSPIRED TO
KEEP MOVING FORWARD, NO MATTER
WHAT.
>> GABBY GIFFORDS, IT'S SUCH A
PLEASURE, AGAIN, TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
BETSY WEST AND JULIE COHEN.
THE NEW